بعد الحادثه المفجعه لقرش التهم سائحا
روسيا السلطات المصريه تعلن غلق شواطئ
الغردقه وحظر ممارسه اي انشطه بحريه لحين
الانتهاء من عمليات مسح الشواطئ لكن ماذا
نعرف عن قرش الغردقه وازاره البيئه
المصريه كشفت ان النوع المنتشره في البحر
الاحمر يعرف بقرش النمر ويصل طوله لنحو
خمسه امتار ويزن حوالي 900 كيلوغرام ويتسم
بسلوكه العدواني اتجاه البشر وهو رابع
اكبر سمكه قرش وثاني اكبر سمكه قرش مفترسه
بعض القرش الابيض الكبير منظمه اوشينا
الامريكيه المعنيه بالحفاظ على المحيطات
قالت ان قرش النمر معروف بهجومه على البشر
لاسيما في المناطق التي تشهد انشطه بحريه
كبيره قائله انه من الاسماك شبه المهدده
بالانقراض حادثه السائحه الروسي ليست
الاولى من نوعها فقد تعرضت امراه لهجوم
قرش في شاطئ الغردقه سنه 2022 ما ادى
لوفاتهما على الفور وعثر ايضا على بقايا
جثه سائح شيكي تعرض لهجوم قرش عام 2018
على احد شواطئ مدينه مرسى علم
[موسيقى]